Remember when "Saturday Night Live" almost
reunited The Beatles? Or when Sinéad O'Connor
got in trouble with the Pope? For a show
that's been going strong for almost 50 years,
it goes without saying that its history is riddled
with all brands of controversy and intrigue.
"Well isn't that special."
In 1974, Johnny Carson was the biggest
moneymaker on television. According
to The New Yorker, he brought
NBC about $60 million a year,
which earned him quite a bit of leverage when
negotiating an extension on his contract to
continue making "The Tonight Show." The program
aired weeknights at 11:30 p.m., and back then,
NBC filled the time slot on Saturdays with a
"Tonight Show" clip show called "The Best of
Carson." But when Carson told NBC he'd only
make four new shows each week, moving "The
Best of Carson" to a weeknight, he left NBC with
a 90-minute hole in the Saturday night schedule.
The network decided to try out a late-night
variety show geared to a young, hip audience.
To run it, executives tapped 30-year-old Canadian
comedy writer Lorne Michaels, best known for his
work on an Emmy-winning Lily Tomlin special. It
took Michaels a year to work out the format and
find a cast of seven sketch comedians, but
in October 1975, the show was ready to go.
During its first season on TV — 1975–76 — the show
wasn't actually called "Saturday Night Live," as
that title was already in use. Sportscaster
Howard Cosell hosted an ABC primetime variety
show with the name and, oddly enough, future "SNL"
star Bill Murray was one of the stock players.
But when that show was canceled, NBC snapped
up the title, replacing the bland original,
"NBC's Saturday Night." That's why at the
beginning of each show, a performer says:
"Live from New York, it's Saturday Night!"
And while the show's opening sequence now features
the main cast and featured players' names read
loudly and excitedly by Darrell Hammond —
who replaced longtime announcer Don Pardo
after his death in 2014 — the "SNL" cast members
weren't introduced individually during the first
season. The obscure comedians were instead dubbed
the "Not Ready for Primetime Players." But Dan
Aykroyd, Chevy Chase, Jane Curtin, Gilda Radner,
and the others, wouldn't stay anonymous for long.
Nowadays, the show is pretty much all comedy with
a couple of musical performances thrown in. But in
the early years, "Saturday Night Live" was a true
variety show. The Muppets were frequent guests on
the late-night circuit in the mid-'70s, so it
only made sense to include them. But we're not
talking about Kermit and the gang here. Instead,
Jim Henson and his cohorts created a whole slew
of new, monstrous, adult-oriented creatures
for a segment called "The Land of Gorch."
"And I'm going to stick my fingers in his ears,
and I'm going to shake him until he's dead!"
It might have been the first and only time
a Muppets project was not well-received.
Considered not as fresh and urgent
as the "SNL" manic sketch comedy,
the segment ground each show to a halt. And due
to Writers Guild rules, the sketches couldn't be
written by Muppets writers — leaving regular
"SNL" writers to do it, and they resented the
puppets for taking up valuable airtime. The
Muppets were gone after the first season.
Per Business Insider, here's the timetable
for how an episode of "SNL" is produced:
Monday: The guest host arrives at 30 Rockefeller
Center in New York City, where "SNL" is shot. They
go to Michaels' office, where they talk to
writers and cast members about their comedic
strengths, impressions they can do, and other
suggestions. Writers then pitch their ideas.
Tuesday: As a holdover from the show's
cocaine-fueled days in the '70s, writers
spend all day and night writing their sketches.
The host and a cast member also shoot short
commercials to promote the episode. They're edited
and put on the air within hours of being shot.
Wednesday: The table read is at 4 p.m. Every
proposed sketch is included, so it usually takes
at least three hours. Then producers and the head
writers determine which sketches are good enough.
Thursday: At 6 a.m., builders begin constructing
sets at a shop in the Brooklyn Navy Yard. At 30
Rock, the crew firms up plans for costumes, wigs,
and makeup. Any pre-taped video bits are recorded.
Friday: Rehearsals are performed
and rewrites are hashed out.
Saturday: The sketch order is set
and presented to a live audience
at 8 p.m. Any last-minute changes happen
by 11:30 p.m. when the show goes live.
After one "SNL" season ends and another begins,
at least a couple of veteran cast members
decide to leave the series. That presents
an opportunity for "SNL" brass to bring in
new performers, which helps keep the show
fresh in terms of comedic voices and styles.
"SNL" talent scouts and producers find those
next-generation and emerging stars who might be
a good fit for the show by casting a wide net.
While they'll consider online comedians and
take recommendations, comedy hotbeds like the
Groundlings in Los Angeles or the Upright Citizens
Brigade in New York often arrange showcases for
top talent, and Michaels and other show staffers,
writers, and cast members attend. If they like
what they see, they invite the performers to an
audition on the "SNL" stage. Hopefuls have 10
minutes to do stand-up or present at least two
original characters and celebrity impressions.
"I'm Penelope Cruz. I'm always searching
for the most perfect moisturizer."
With more than a dozen performers and
at least that many writers in direct
competition with each other to fill just
about an hour of sketch time, somebody is
going to get left out. In his book "Gasping for
Airtime," former cast member Jay Mohr said he
was so desperate to get a sketch on the air
in 1995, that he stole a routine by comedian
Rick Shapiro and turned it into "O'Callahan &
Son Pub." Two months later, "SNL" fired Mohr.
And while Larry David eventually went on to
co-create "Seinfeld" and star in "Curb Your
Enthusiasm," he had an uneventful spell
as an "SNL" writer in 1984. Back then,
only one of his sketches made it to air: an odd
piece called "Going Up." In it, an architect
becomes frustrated that a client wants to make
sure that the elevators in the new building
have stools for elevator operators. David later
recycled the bit for an episode of "Seinfeld."
"Not bad!"
It's obvious which guest hosts "SNL" likes the
most, because they're the ones who keep coming
back. Steve Martin, Alec Baldwin, Woody
Harrelson, and Melissa McCarthy are a few
who have meshed well with the program. On the
other end of the spectrum, there are hosts who
will likely never return because they were
difficult to work with, obnoxious, or both.
In a 1992 episode, host Nicolas
Cage confides to Michaels that
he fears he'll be the worst host in
the show's history. Michaels replies:
"No, no. That would be Steven Seagal."
Al Franken wrote that joke, but many
SNL alumni, including David Spade,
have named the martial arts
actor the show's worst host.
But according to Michaels, the worst was
probably early TV star Milton Berle, who guested
in 1979 and disrupted the show with mugging,
ad-libbing of old and tired jokes, and arranged
beforehand to have the studio audience give him
a standing ovation at the end. Tina Fey, however,
didn't beat around the bush when she told Howard
Stern who she thought was the worst: Paris Hilton.
"That's hot."
While many of the show's performers
come from an improv comedy background,
it's forbidden to improvise on SNL. The
show has to be planned down to the second
to account for each sketch, musical
performance, and a commercial break.
But not every host and musical guest follows
that rule, and many were subsequently banned.
In 2003, Adrien Brody did an impromptu,
borderline racist bit with a Jamaican
accent while introducing reggae singer Sean
Paul. In 1996, Rage Against the Machine asked
for two upside-down American flags to be hung on
the stage. When producers said no, the band hung
them up anyway. Stagehands tore them down just
seconds before they were supposed to perform, and
their second song was canceled. The musicians were
escorted from the building before the episode had
even finished. Sen Dog of Cypress Hill claimed his
group earned a ban after smoking marijuana during
their "SNL" performance. And let's not forget
Sinead O'Connor's infamous pope incident in 1992.
Just because an "SNL" episode airs, it doesn't
mean it stays that way forever. Producers often
tinker with shows for reruns, replacing a sketch
that went poorly with a superior version recorded
during dress rehearsal. That means some "lost"
sketches only survive on DVD and streaming
versions. One of them, "Butt County Dance Party,"
aired in 1976. In the sketch, a small-town sheriff
played by Dan Akroyd hosts a TV dance show, and
"winners" get to have their names run through
a teletype machine to check for outstanding
warrants. But when the machine malfunctioned,
Akroyd tried to improvise and told everyone
to keep dancing, although there was no
music. NBC cut to random stock footage of car
crashes, then pulled the sketch from reruns.
In another instance from 1985, NBC president
Brandon Tartikoff appeared in a sketch to
collect urine samples from cast members for
drug testing, but it was later deemed to be
in poor taste. In the reruns, it's swapped out
for an extra musical performance by Simple Minds.
For decades, each episode of "Saturday Night
Live" has basically followed the same format:
a bunch of standalone sketches, a couple of
musical performances, and "Weekend Update"
somewhere in the middle. In 1986, that
all went out the window — but just once,
to cater to a very special guest. Acclaimed
director Francis Ford Coppola was the host,
and the through-line of the episode was
that Coppola was "directing" the show.
The credits were stylized like those of an
art film and the music was provided by that
night's musical guest, avant-garde composer,
Philip Glass. "Cheers" star George Wendt was
on hand to deliver the opening monologue and
appeared in sketches, while Coppola didn't act
in anything apart from appearing as himself,
sitting in a director's chair and interrupting
the show every few minutes to critique the actors'
performances or other aspects of the production.
"Dennis, you can't do a satellite interview
with Pinochet, it's too much like Ted KOH-puhl."
"KAH-puhl."
"Sorry, KAH-puhl. Anyway, it's not original."
He also appeared in vignettes with Michaels
and cast member Terry Sweeney to discuss
innovative ways to save the show, which NBC
was actually considering canceling at the time.
Many of the most popular "SNL" characters
have been spun off into feature films,
but very few of them have been
financially successful. Some of
these include "The Blues Brothers"
and the classic "Wayne's World."
"Does this guy know how to party, or what?"
It's the $100 million-plus box office
take of the latter that encouraged the
production of more and more "SNL" movies
in the 1990s and early 2000s. "A Night at
the Roxbury" offered a look at the backstory
and home life of those unnamed guys — played
by Will Ferrell and Chris Kattan — who bobbed
their heads to Haddaway's "What is Love?" and
tried to pick up uninterested women in
a series of sketches in the mid-1990s.
It earned a respectable $30 million at the
box office in 1999, and so did "Superstar,"
about Molly Shannon's awkward schoolgirl
character, Mary Katherine Gallagher.
"Superstar!"
Other films didn't fare so well. "It's Pat,"
revolving around Julia Sweeney's character, Pat
Riley — the joke being that people couldn't figure
out the character's gender — barely saw release in
1994, nor did Al Franken's Stuart Smalley vehicle,
"Stuart Saves His Family," the following year. As
of 2023, the last "SNL"-based movie to see a
theatrical release was "MacGruber" in 2010.
Not every single aspect of "Saturday
Night Live" is produced as its live
broadcast. Since the beginning of the
show in the 1970s, pre-taped segments,
short films, and commercial parodies
have almost always been a part of
the "SNL" format. Tom Schiller produced
standalone films for "SNL" in its early
years, such as the flash-forward death
meditation, "Don't Look Back in Anger."
"They're all dead…I'll tell
you why…Because I'm a dancer."
In the '70s, comedian and filmmaker Albert Brooks
rejected Michaels' offer to make him the show's
permanent host and instead offered to create
short films. Mockumentary master Christopher
Guest also contributed short features as
a cast member in the '80s. Robert Smigel's
animated "TV Funhouse" anthology — featuring
"The X-Presidents," "Fun With Real Audio,"
and "The Ambiguously Gay Duo," broke up "SNL"
episodes in the 2000s. And The Lonely Island
brought more than just Andy Samberg to "Saturday
Night Live" — they also brought comic rap videos
and viral hits like "Lazy Sunday" and "I'm
on a Boat." In 2021, "SNL" brought on the
internet comedy troupe Please Don't Destroy
to produce semi-weekly videos for the show.
Once they've finally made it into
the cast of "SNL," the worrying
doesn't end for performers. They
can and have been abruptly fired
from the show. Damon Wayans told The
Weekender of his 1985-1986 tenure:
"They didn't let me do what
I wanted to do on 'SNL.'"
He got so frustrated that he did
something he knew would lead to his
termination — he deviated from script
and rehearsal and in a live sketch,
portrayed a police officer character
as a flamboyant LGBTQ stereotype.
In 1995, "SNL" cleaned house. In
the wake of a blistering New York
Magazine cover story that hailed the show's
demise, and as ratings subsequently fell,
Michaels fired nearly everyone — including
major standouts like Adam Sandler and Chris
Farley. David Spade, Tim Meadows, and a
few others were spared. The next season,
Michaels brought on new hires like Will
Ferrell, Jim Breuer, and Cheri Oteri.
And in 1998, NBC executive Dick Ebersol —
who helped develop "SNL" in the '70s — fired
"Weekend Update" anchor Norm MacDonald,
reportedly due to his constant jokes
about accused killer O.J. Simpson; Ebersol
happened to be one of Simpson's friends.
"She exclaimed, 'He did
it!'... Reached for comment,
O.J. said 'My mom was just guessing.
I hadn't even told her yet."
More recently, Taran Killam and Jay Pharaoh
were both let go after six years on the show.
Only a couple hundred performers have ever
been full-fledged "SNL" cast members. It's
an achievement unto itself for a young comedian,
if not a launchpad to future entertainment world
success. But some people's time with the show
ended before it could even begin. During the
1980-1981 season, Emily Prager and Laurie
Metcalf joined "SNL" as featured players.
A writers' strike ended the "SNL"
season prematurely at 13 episodes,
by which point Metcalf had appeared in
only a few segments and Prager hadn't
appeared at all. They exited the cast
shortly thereafter. Emmy Award-winning
actor Catherine O'Hara actually
joined "SNL" in the early '80s,
during a hiatus from Canada's "SCTV," and quit
a couple of weeks before the "SNL" season began
airing — although she did go on to have a turn
as a host in 1992. O'Hara told the Toronto Star:
"I hung out with some nice people,
tried to come up with some ideas,
but I never really felt involved."
In September 2019, "SNL" announced that comedian
and podcaster Shane Gillis had landed a spot in
the cast. Within the week, footage of
Gillis uttering slurs on his podcast,
offensive to people of Chinese descent
and to members of the LGBTQ community,
surfaced online and went viral. Days later, before
ever appearing on the show, Gillis was fired.
According to the New York Post, six years after
the Beatles split up in 1970, concert promoter
Sid Bernstein offered the Fab Four a whopping $230
million to get back together and go on tour. The
band members declined, but the cultural incident
was fresh in the minds of "Saturday Night Live"
viewers later that year — so Michaels went on
camera in September 1976 and pleaded with the
Beatles to reunite on his show and play three
songs for a comically small amount of money.
"I was authorized by NBC to pay
them the sum of three thousand
dollars. That was three thousand
dollars for just three songs."
It was all a joke, but unbeknownst to Michaels
at the time, two Beatles actually considered
accepting. Paul McCartney and John Lennon
happened to be together watching "SNL" on
TV at Lennon's apartment when Michaels made
his pitch. McCartney told Rock News Desk:
"John said, 'We should go down, just you and
me. There's only two of us so we'll take half
the money.' But it would have been work, and we
were having a night off, so we elected not to go."
Five years into "SNL," Michaels needed a break.
In case he departed entirely, he picked staff
writer and cast member Al Franken to be his
replacement. Two days before a discussion with
NBC president Fred Silverman, Franken appeared in
a "Weekend Update" segment called "Limo for the
Lame-O," criticizing Silverman for charging NBC
for car service despite the network's failures.
"The guy's been here two years, and hasn't
done diddly-squat. And he gets a limo. Now…"
That enraged Silverman and led to such animosity
toward "SNL" that Michaels wound
up leaving the show altogether.
NBC appointed inexperienced TV producer Jean
Doumanian to replace Michaels. Her first task:
hire new performers, as most of the old ones left
with Michaels. Doumanian hired stars like Eddie
Murphy and Joe Piscopo, while the show cycled
through writers. During the 1980-81 season,
"SNL" lost 30% of its audience while
critics lamented the slide in quality.
The 11th episode of the season featured
an extended riff on the "Who Shot J.R.?"
storyline from "Dallas," with cast member
Charles Rocket faux-shot. During the show's
"goodnights," guest host Charlene Tilton asked
a wheelchair-bound Rocket how he felt. He said:
"It's the first time I've ever been shot in
my life. I'd like to know who the f— did it."
One episode later, NBC fired
Doumanian. Soon after that,
Rocket was let go as well. A writer's
strike followed, and the season ended early.
"Saturday Night Live" is a high-profile pinnacle
of comedy, but it's not for everyone. Now best
known for "Strangers with Candy" and "BoJack
Horseman," Amy Sedaris was performing her comic
stage show "One Woman Shoe" in 1995 when
Michaels approached her about replacing
abruptly departed cast member Janeane
Garofalo. Sedaris told writer David Rakoff:
"It was everything I wanted. Maybe even three
years earlier it would have been great."
Right around the time she landed a breakout role
on "Friends" in the mid-1990s, Jennifer Aniston
met with Michaels and turned down the chance
to be in the "SNL cast." She recalled telling
Michaels about the show's boys club atmosphere
during an appearance on "The Howard Stern Show":
"I didn't think I would like that environment."
Johnny Knoxville passed on "SNL" in
two different ways. Knoxville and a
team of skateboarders put together a
pilot of themselves performing wild,
humorous pranks and stunts. That project aired
on MTV as "Jackass" after Knoxville turned down
a weekly spot for the concept on "SNL," because
they'd have more control over the material on
cable. "SNL" then asked Knoxville, alone, to
join the cast. He told the Washington Times:
"It was at the point where I
either say yes to my friends,
where we had all the control or yes to
'Saturday Night Live,' where none of
my friends were really going to
be there and I had no control."
"Saturday Night Live" writers are unionized
and part of the Writers Guild of America.
When the organization goes on strike,
it ends production on most scripted
television series. Two such stoppages
resulted in unique "Saturday Night Live"
presentations made by "SNL" cast and writers
and presented live, but never aired on TV.
According to "The War for Late Night" book,
when the 1988 writers' strike caused "SNL" to
wrap up the 1987-88 season early, writers Robert
Smigel and Bob Odenkirk took all the sketches they
didn't think would ever make it into a broadcast
episode of "SNL." After recruiting future writers
Conan O'Brien and Greg Daniels, the group put
on "The Happy Happy Good Show" at a theater in
Chicago. Among the sketches in the presentation
was "Chicago Superfans," which would later be
a recurring "SNL" bit called "Bill Swerski's
Superfans," responsible for the catchphrase:
"Da Bears."
During the 2007-2008 WGA strike, the Upright
Citizens Brigade Theater in New York hosted
a complete "SNL" episode for a live audience.
With proceeds benefiting furloughed "SNL" staff,
most of the show's regular cast at the
time — including Fred Armisen, Seth Meyers,
Darrell Hammond, Kenan Thompson, and Amy Poehler
— participated. Michael Cera served as guest host,
and Yo La Tengo was the musical guest. Because
of the writers' strike, the sketches were written
months or years earlier — all of them consisting
of things rejected for the TV version of "SNL."
It's not uncommon to meet a romantic partner
in the workplace, and "Saturday Night Live"
seems to be the kind of place where people
make lasting love connections. "Star Wars"
favorite Carrie Fisher hosted "SNL" in 1978 and
met Dan Aykroyd there, but according to Aykroyd,
their romance began while filming "The Blues
Brothers." Scarlett Johansson hosted "SNL"
in 2006 when Colin Jost was a writer on the
show, and they worked on a sketch together
in 2010 when Johansson returned. By 2017, they
were an official couple; they married in 2020.
"And I met the love of my
life here. Merry Christmas."
Writer-director Dave McCary helmed
the "SNL" short "Wells for Boys"
during an episode hosted by Emma
Stone, whom he'd later marry.
When "Mad Men" star Jon Hamm hosted "SNL" in
2008, he brought along costar Elisabeth Moss
for a cameo in a sketch, where she met fellow
cast member Fred Armisen — the pair married in
2009 and split up in 2010. Cast member Cecily
Strong dated featured player and writer Mike
O'Brien in 2014. Pete Davidson met comedian
Cazzie David when her father, Larry David,
hosted the show in 2015. Davidson broke things
off in 2018, and days later began a relationship
with Ariana Grande, whom he'd first met when
she appeared on "SNL" in 2016. Davidson later
enjoyed a romance with Kim Kardashian, whom he
connected with after her 2021 hosting stint.
Alongside the ever-changing cast of actors
and comedians on "Saturday Night Live" each
week is the show's house band. A collective of
experienced, professional musicians spanning
many genres, a number of major stars have spent
some time playing the "SNL" opening and closing
themes, jazzy-pop interstitial tunes, and
sketch accompaniment music as required.
Howard Shore, who'd later go on to win Oscars
for two "The Lord of the Rings" movies,
wrote the "SNL" theme song and served
as the show's first musical director,
following collaborations with Lorne Michaels
on Canadian variety TV shows. The 1972 Toronto
production of the musical "Godspell" involved
future "SNL" greats Gilda Radner and Martin Short,
while Paul Shaffer played in the orchestra. Before
joining the "SNL" cast as an actor — and before a
33-year stint as David Letterman's bandleader
— Shaffer played keyboards in the "SNL" band.
Guitarist G.E. Smith became moderately famous as
a member of Daryl Hall and John Oates' backing
band during their hit-making days in the
1980s, but needed work when the duo called
for an indefinite hiatus in 1985. That's when
Michaels returned to "SNL" after his own hiatus,
and according to The Morning Call, he
asked Smith to be the show's bandleader.
Still photography comprises a big part of both
the look and flow of "Saturday Night Live."
In transitioning to and from commercial breaks,
"SNL" puts up photos of each episode's guest host,
generally of a humorous and whimsical nature.
Since 1999, "SNL" official photographer Mary
Ellen Matthews is the person responsible
for those "bumper" celebrity portraits.
Matthews takes the job seriously,
aiming to make the host comfortable enough to
let loose and be creative. She told Vulture:
"I like to make it as easy as possible for
everyone. I don't want them overthinking
this part of the show. It should be super fun and
super easy. It's an open invitation to get kooky."
The "SNL" production schedule is so tightly
packed that Matthews and a handful of costume
and prop assistants get no more than
90 minutes over the span of two days to
shoot an entire episode's bumpers, about
four or five different visual scenarios,
which makes proper planning key. Matthews added:
"We try to find out who's
hosting as far in advance
as possible so we can start thinking about it."
In 2021, Lorne Michaels told reporters that he
might be winding down work
on the comedy institution.
"My plan is to be here for the 50th. And by that
point, I really deserve to, uh, wander off."
Michaels doesn't want "SNL" to end with his exit,
however, and he claims to have
secretly selected his successor.
Less than a year later, Charlamagne
tha God reported on his show,
"Hell of a Week," a rumor that NBC may
pull the plug on "SNL" when Michaels
leaves after Season 50. "Hell of a Week"
guest Kenan Thompson — the longest-tenured
cast member in the history of the
show — didn't deny the gossip.
"There could be a lot of validity
to that rumor because 50 is a good
number to stop at, ya know what I'm saying?"